オレは映画をですよ見て普通に憧れ
火星には黄金宇宙飛行士に憧れたなんとかしてる通知コースになりたいと思った俺は
部痛服を
手に入れた
ハイパーぬーっ
になりたかったよね
イブのカードだよっしゃーっ
800 w 頑張って自然ということですね
やさしくして正肥通りですえっいうかな
課題は以下たん
米崎つ一つ言えるのは
壮絶置いてる所としてねこれ30キロぐらいのでおそらく
year
ぶー敗着 mg できました
ブーバと思っていますではいろいろちょっとやってみましょう
ぶーぶーっ
音がいいですね口動きターンはスマートフォンの操作ができるのは行ってみようと思い
ます指が太いんだよねそうしにくかったさんやめだと思っておっさんになってること
です
配牌なぁをちょっと月降りてみようと思います体が太いのでどれくらい平気なのかを
すこ
実際にやっていると思ううーん
あーはいはいネタも塗っ
ゲートれるんだよへんねん実際に杖を書いてみようと思いますけどいいけど
goo ん
全米ずれてみたんですけど持ってどちら妹なりましたでもここは重力なる空間なので
本当だっても初期んじゃないですか実際にちょっとこっちに飛ん前館長
解決しないんだろ御台所ちょっと voodoo と思います
いやああああああし
プー宙ブランコができる場所に来ましたもう結構お高いんですけどもが国愚痴ってる
わけなんて宇宙の気分をこのまま楽しめればいいなと思っております
いや実際に宇宙を体感してみましょういくぜ
チークなのはジャンプしブラントといただくことはできません
あっ
ひとまず宇宙だけが体験しようと思っているのでちょっと
クルーズブランコやってみると思います
行ってきますどちらと思う
me はなりませんいろいろん
9分
ええええええ
meji
me
ana 0
goo
nao
ああああああ
はぁ
a
うん
ああああああ
goo
ています
hey
me
はぁ
none
ないすればいいよいいよ
boku wa nai
a
ああああああ
carre
re
ああああああ
普通
感じることができました入ってあげていかがだったでしょうか空中ブランコ
あれタイミング出さなきゃいけないずどっちの日なきゃダメなんで凄い難しい自身は
うまくいって良かったらですほとんどなしかなり練習しますその際て指でオデッセイな
んですけどもう宇宙の無重力の空間の中でのねああいうちょっとアクションチップ無し
もあるのでそちらも
ぜひ楽しみて言っていただけるとありがたいです本当にた資金なのでぜひ見てください
あそしてパトリーは稼いで生き延びるヒントができるのか
火傷して+かかるのかオデッセイ僕からのコンボに掘って目指せ百均でぜひ見て
ください
前の動画の入ったんですけどでしてこういう音をでしてプラント
植物が今もらえ
みたいです結構大きくですかな入金止めてきたんですけどももしかせず取り残される
ことだったらこういう植物さまで家からとても大切でよかったらこれ育ててみたいなっ
て思った人車の動画説明欄から応募できますのでよかったらこのオデッセイプラントを
育ててみてくださいただで貰えるみたいなじゃあ
ていました
bejean